Have you ever had the winter blues? Where you're just depressed during the
winter? For some people, this is an actual recognized disorder called seasonal
affective disorder. This applies to any season. Throughout most of the year,
people with SAD have normal mental health, but experience depression during
certain seasons, even, Even spring or summer. Researchers tried to figure out
how to treat SAD. 95 people were randomly assigned to one of three conditions.
Bright light therapy which is where participants were exposed to 10,000 lux for
30 minutes every morning From 6 o'clock until 6:30 a.m.
Lux is the international standard measurement of illuminance. The second group
received dawn simulation, which was a dawn signal in which people were exposed
to lux that peaked at 250. And this lasted 1.5 hours, and the third was a
placebo condition, which was just 1.5 hours of a dim red light at only .5 lux.
This lasted from 4:30AM until 6:00AM.
The number of people in each group was as follows, 33 in the bright light, 31 in
the dawn simulation, and 31 in the placebo. After six weeks, all the subjects
were blindly rated by a psychiatrist. So the psychiatrist did not know which
treatment each person was exposed to. The psychiatrist uses the structured
interview guide for the Hamilton Depression ration for seasonal affective
disorder. This measures a person's level of this type of depression on a scale
of 0 to 89, with higher numbers indicating greater severity of depression. The
researchers found that dawn simulation was associated with greater recovery.
That is compared to the placebo group and the bright light therapy group.